now but first
new concerns for parents whose kids are
being forced to wear masks in schools
from washington state to california
students are fed up and are staging
walkouts in protest and in virginia
students in several districts will have
to continue wearing masks after a judge
temporarily blocked governor younkin's
executive order to make schools mask
optional now the governor's press
secretary slamming the ruling tweeting
in part this is not a pro mask or
anti-mass debate it's about parents
knowing what's best for their child's
health and backlash growing over a
california substitute teacher who
berated a student for wearing a thin
blue line mask to honor his father who
is a police officer here's what happened
in that classroom
it's the new confederacy plan no it's
not that's what you're doing well we
can't do the confederate but we can put
up red white and blue no it's black
white with some blue line in it yeah i
think blue line yeah but it's not
american
my my uh it's like what what is going on
there uh let me go right to you actually
on this alicia this is a very good
example of the madness that we very
rarely see in classrooms but now
everybody thank goodness has their phone
and their camera uh what's your take on
this
yeah thank god that the kids had their
their phone right and were able to
record on this otherwise it would just
be their word against this substitute
teacher i find it infuriating and i
should note that the substitute teacher
there um according to the mom of that
that kid who was wearing that mask the
principal said that he's no longer going
to be working at that school but which
brings to mind the question will he be
working at other schools
it's really sad and really icky timing
because you think about the the members
of law enforcement who were laid to rest
this past week you have this son of a
law enforcement member who is trying to
honor his father only to be berated and
embarrassed by his substitute teacher
yeah in front of in front of everyone
that teacher seemed to not even know
what he was talking about but that's all
also nothing new i want you guys to hear
this is from the student uh who was
berated by that teacher and his mom on
what unfolded in the classroom
i was sitting down doing my work and he
sat in the desk desk behind me he told
me it was not a real american flag kept
saying that it's un-american everybody
is just extremely shocked um and
obviously angry um i'm pretty
heartbroken that this is even an issue
that he had to deal with this but
um
at the same time
proud um that he reacted the way that he
did and he stood up for
um what he's so passionate about and
what he believes in
that that is excellent you know sean we
we talk about parents getting
radicalized it looks like students are
getting radicalized i love that they
both were comfortable in front of a
camera that this kid was was proud
we i want to get you a few more details
about what's happening on the on the
left coast as well with students
stepping out on this uh is this good
news i think it is across the country
well it is good news because first we
have parents who are actually teaching
their kids to stand up and fight for
freedom which by the way it's
interesting that we're actually having a
lot of americans ask their government to
give them their freedom back god
actually gave us our freedom god made us
free we shouldn't ask our government to
give it to us number one but what i
think is interesting is you know you
have this scenario where you have this
you know leftist teacher who's actually
an idiot by the way i don't know how he
graduated from a teacher's college but
these are leftists and we used to think
back in the 70s and 80s and 90s when
some of us went to high school these are
not the same teachers these have been
radicalized in teachers in their in the
teachers colleges and they've now come
into the classroom and they're espousing
these radical marxist beliefs to our
kids and
listen i don't know how you deal with
this it's going to take i think i think
generations to deal with the school
system and the teachers if you have the
if you have the funding and the
resources in a school near you go to a
classical education get your kids out of
the public school ask your parents or
aunts and uncles to help out and save
your kids by getting them out of this
garbage because it's it's penetrating
the minds of young kids and destroying i
think our future well and the the good
news is joe i want everybody to watch
this we've got some video of kids who
were blocked in a gym
because they refused to wear a mask
there are these tables up at the doors
you're going to see this
and also they've alleged that then an
adult a teacher or a member of staff
turned off the heat
to freeze them out do we have i think we
have that video can we see that
all right well
it's all over the internet i guess we
don't have the actual video there there
are pictures up
and uh i guess the the thermostat issue
is is uh uh being debated about whether
or not that occurred but joe here you've
got videos like that you've got uh
accusations like that and then i think
do we have we have video of some of the
kids storming out of one of those
classrooms and and of the the school
uh on the on the on the west coast
uh you know
so i
ca
can we see that
that would be great
all right we're now walking into the
school with no mask on
you can get me in trouble they can
suspend me i don't care we're done with
this
and obviously all of you are too we want
this to be a peaceful respectful
movement we are just trying to gain back
our rights as citizens
well now you see joe i mean this is what
we're talking about that kid very very
good kind of radicalized but isn't this
the american spirit
i'd say that video is worth waiting for
tammy said i'm glad you pressed for it
it is the american spirit it's also the
american sentiment right there's a poll
out today 70 percent of americans seven
and 10 said okay we're done with covet
we just need to learn to live with that
that is a drastically different number
than where we were even a couple of
months ago and it seems like every day i
got to see a photo or photos of some
democratic politician or some member of
a teachers union or some members of a
school board or some state senator who
is out with their friends they're at
like the double deuce or the peach pit
they're socializing without a mask rules
for thee not for these uh these as in
democrats and then the next day they're
demanding your kid my kid they have to
wear a mask for hours on end we're in
our third year of this all in the name
of public safety my kindergartner
doesn't remember a time tammy
from preschool on up until now where he
hasn't worn a mask at school think about
that and this is happening by the way
and this is the date and the science
that we're told to follow as covet cases
are plummeting across the country in
loudoun county virginia alone the
epicenter of this mass fight where
there's a population of more than 400
000 people they're averaging about 200
cases per day and i asked alexa to
figure it out for me and that's
0.06 of the population public health
protecting teachers and kids right you
know alicia i'll give you the last word
on this because with all these kids
having you know they're pushing back now
they're seeing it on tick tock they're
seeing it on social media this is really
giving some permission to the kids to
take you know a stand against what they
think is entertainment also keep that
keep in mind three weeks ago there were
kids who were protesting in cities
saying they didn't feel protected enough
from covet so you have people kids also
protesting the mask so the message i'm
hearing the kids don't trust the adults
to take care of business and they're
frustrated regardless of the side that
they're on
yeah there you go and of course it's
about the influence of the parents which
is what the teachers unions seem to be
upset about as well hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else